Welcome back everyone this will be my full
avengers 5 kang dynasty in avengers 6 secret
wars video with all the marvel phase 5 and marvel
phase 6 movies and disney plus series that they
put on the schedule there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs obviously this is a really huge deal
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of course i'll
be doing videos for all the stuff all the episodes
they drop all the movies that they drop it's gonna
be awesome i'm so happy that they announced all
this stuff like clearly they wanted to remind you
like oh yeah we have a direction we're headed in i
think we all knew that they were building up to a
version of secret wars but now we have a clear
answer as to what most of this is going to be
there were a couple movies and a couple disney
plus series that they've already announced but
didn't put on the official schedules here on the
board and there were a couple blank mystery movie
dates in disney plus mystery dates that they'll
mostly announce at d23 later this year like if
you can believe it they were holding back on some
announcements like we'll hold some secrets back
until d23 because that's when we're really getting
out some big stuff we'll get a lot more trailers
and a lot more promos for the upcoming stuff
during that and that's gonna happen in september
but we already know what some of those mystery
movies and mystery series are going to be so
i'll talk about those later in the video the real
big thing is avengers 5 kang dynasty in avengers 6
secret wars them using the teaser to confirm what
their grand plan is for the next saga of marvel
movies phase 4 phase 5 and phasics and they're
just calling it the multiverse saga like phase
1 phase 2 and phase 3 where the infinity saga
now it's the multiverse saga i was calling it
the secret war saga before this but the multiverse
saga works well too kevin feige said the reason
why this saga is happening so quickly compared to
how long it took to get through all of the marvel
phase 1 phase 2 and phase 3 movies is just because
they didn't have the marvel disney plus series
before so there was just way less time for them to
spend telling the story during those earlier years
like early on they only had like one two movies
per year now they have like three or four movies
per year and like three or four at disney plus
series minimum so it'll be like this when we get
to marvel phase seven phase eight phase whatever
they call the phases after phase six who knows if
we'll get to like phase 25 and they'll just start
calling it something different like will they call
it phase 100 when we're all in our 90s the bigger
announcement i think is that they plan at least
right now on releasing two giant avengers movies
avengers 5 avengers 6 in the same calendar year
like they're going full matrix with it if you
don't remember the classic matrix movies or you
didn't see those in theaters they did the exact
same thing with the matrix sequels just waiting a
couple months between like the giant sequels what
i'm expecting is that we'll get a couple years
down the road and they'll just say oh you know by
the way we've decided to push avengers 6 secret
wars to the following spring and it'll be just
like the way that they released avengers infinity
war and avengers end game it'll be like one
calendar year between the movies but the reason
why they want to have them so close together is
because they're doing the exact same thing that
they did with the story of avengers infinity
war and avengers end game like it's one giant
avengers story meant to bookend an entire saga of
movies but the stories of each of the movies is a
little bit different so they give them different
titles like it's not part one and part two
and they release them relatively close together
and they'll just break the story in half with a
giant cliffhanger like they did with infinity war
during infinity war it was the snap this time it's
going to be like the time runs out scenario where
like the rest of the multiverse just collapses on
itself and you have battle world at the end of
the film so the whole idea is that at the end
of avengers 5 kang dynasty the new avengers team
whoever the new roster is going to be winds up
losing again like you have a kind of a
downer ending as they head into battle world
and they'll have a similar moment like they had
in the comics with doctor strange and doctor doom
where doom became god emperor doom and combined
all the remnants of the remaining universes into
a single universe with a single world and that
was battleworld in early theory avengers 6 will
probably begin with all the characters from a
bunch of different universes like the fox marvel
movies every character you could possibly imagine
coming back as a version of their character
waking up on battle world believing that the
universe that they now exist in this battle world
scenario is the way that things have always been
with only a couple of the characters remembering
the multiverse that came before but the big change
here i think we're all expecting because of the
way they announced all these movies and because
kevin feige said that jonathan majors as king
the conquerors variants of king the conquer will
be such a big character during all this is that
instead a lot of this story turning around god
emperor doom pulling all the strings during secret
words it'll be a version of jonathan major's
king the conqueror and he's kind of like the next
version of thanos where like you have versions of
thanos in avengers infinity war in avengers end
game so the story is all about them versus thanos
but in both movies it's like slightly different
versions of thanos so if you're wondering who the
next thanos was going to be a lot of you predicted
that it would be kang you are right pat yourselves
on the back what's going on with avengers 5 kang
dynasty though is that they'll probably do a
version of the kang war from the comics with some
minor changes just so that everything fits with
the continuity that they've done in the previous
marvel movies like the roster of new avengers will
be a little bit different based on what they've
set up in the movie so far based on the marvel
phase 5 schedule and the way they transition
to marvel phase six and when everything is coming
out they'll probably tease that new avengers team
coming together during captain america four new
world order like they'll do it as a mini avengers
crossover movie kind of like civil war with a
bunch of avengers in it and they'll just tease
them all forming a new team of avengers at the
end of that and then over the course of marvel
phase six we'll slowly see that team actually come
together so that by the time you get to the end of
marvel phase six you have the new avengers
team kang does something big and you head
into avengers 5. if you haven't read that newer
version of kang war in the comics it happened
around the same time that the newer secret wars
also happened it was a brand new avengers roster
with some of the versions on that team being
characters that we just met in marvel phase 4.
now like i said the roster won't be the exact same
as it was in the comics but it'll be pretty close
it was them fighting different versions of kang
from across his timeline in the past the present
the future in the loki finale he who remains kang
teased that they'd meet many of his variants from
across different timelines some of them with
different names he said that he himself had
also been called many different names across time
that was meant to be a reference to the different
comic book versions of the character like rama
tut who we got easter eggs for during the loki
series and loki season one the scarlet centurion
king the conqueror immortus now add he who remains
to that list because they used to be two different
characters in the comics but they kind of combined
them into the same character during the loki
finale there's even a version of iron lad that
they haven't introduced yet who's basically like
a child version of kang he becomes someone called
kid immortus who's like another version of the
character so there are many many many versions
of him we'll probably see in future marvel movies
ant-man 3 is like the next big place because we'll
see a version of king the conqueror in that and
then again during loki season 2 and what'll happen
during avengers 5 is they'll also probably pay
off a bigger version of the kang multiverse award
that they kept talking about during the loki
series but you didn't actually see it happen
kevin feige teased that when they introduced that
concept to the multiverse war in the loki series
and still be killed he who remains unleashing the
other king variants in the second kang multiverse
war like it all started happening again that
was meant to be the beginning of everything that
they're culminating with avengers 5 and avengers
6. so it's all connected classic marvel line and
if it wasn't clear the version of secret wars that
they'll do during avengers 6 will be a combination
of the newer secret wars with some changes like i
said so that it fits with all the characters that
they've set up in the current marvel movies it
won't be exactly like it was in the comics but
they'll also probably include some easter eggs for
the classic 80s version of secret wars which was a
completely different storyline but they actually
did a version of that during the 90s spider-man
the animated series great series but it was very
different from the newer version that they'll
probably be basing the movie on right now as we're
talking black panther wakanda forever is the end
of marvel phase four ant-man three quantum
mania is the beginning of marvel phase five
i literally just did an ant-man 3 trailer video
for all the footage they released at comic con
so i'll add a link for that at the end of this and
in the description below so you can watch it again
it features ant-man versus a version of kang
the conqueror we'll also see a version of kang
during loki season 2 that same year maybe
different variants of kang in both projects
but we'll see like i said the only things that
they left off the schedule here in marvel phase
five is what if season two that's happening
around the same time that ant-man 3 is coming out
there's also that spider-man freshman year
series that they announced that's coming out
during marvel phase 5 that they didn't put on the
board here and yes armor wars is still coming out
but they didn't put it on the marvel phase five
or marvel phase six schedule that's probably
just because they're waiting to figure out a
release date it's pretty early in development
it will probably fall during marvel phase six
during one of these mystery dates the biggest
announcements of marvel phase 5 in my opinion are
the new daredevil born again series which we knew
was eventually going to happen we just didn't know
when or how they were going to do it they also
confirmed that's going to have 18 episodes like
we just saw him in the she-hulk trailer that's
like the next step in him coming back into this
new revival series the other big confirmation is
that thunderbolts is going to be the end of marvel
phase 5. that means they'll also probably tease
the thunderbolts coming together during captain
america 4. the beginning of marvel phase 6 is
the brand new fantastic four movie and notice how
the logo for avengers 5 kang dynasty is the same
blue color as the fantastic four logo and it's the
same blue color that you see coming off of kang's
time travel technology in the ant-man 3 trailer
inside the quantum realm that's no coincidence
because there is a huge connection between the
fantastic four and king kang's original name as
you'll remember is nathaniel richards he was
named after reed richard's father so kang and
reed richards are like very very distantly related
the other reason for the blue coloring is that it
also confirms that both of them are using quantum
energy to power their portal technology and in
kang's cases time travel technology which makes
sense i was talking about this back when loki
season 1 came out and again when we saw john
krasinski's reed richards using the blue portal
technology in doctor strange too like they're just
confirming that connection now the reason why the
avengers 6 secret wars logo looks so different
looks black basically is because it's meant to
represent the void of nothingness like of all
reality collapsing that they exist in after the
last incursions and after the multiverse basically
dies like the avengers lose all of reality
collapses except for this one universe with this
one world in that universe called battle world the
whole thing with the thor love and thunder post
credit scene teasing hercules going after thor
seems like it's setting up a version of war of the
realms which is sort of like a god tier version
of avengers end game with like all the gods
going at each other i'm really hoping that
they don't try to shoehorn that in and also do it
during secret wars and they do it as just like a
completely separate thing because it is totally
different from what happens during secret wars
as for all the mystery dates in marvel phase
six we already know what most of these will be i
already said armor wars is coming out in phase six
they have the wonder man series there's an okoye
series there's a separate wakanda disney plus
series there's a nova series they just announced
we know about deadpool 3 coming out shangshi 2
has already been confirmed with the same director
daniel cretton he's also the person who's going
to direct avengers 5 kang dynasty but they did
confirm that they'd have a completely different
director for avengers 6 secret wars and the russo
said that it probably would not be them we'll see
if they pick ryan coogler or one of the other new
directors that comes along during marvel phase
5. we also know they have spider-man 4 coming
with tom holland there's also the new x-men movie
they announced which is currently just called the
mutants so that's at least seven projects in their
eight empty slots in marvel phase six so that last
remaining slot might wind up being dr strange
three but like any of those marvel disney plus
series that are early in development could get
pushed to marvel phase seven even the x-men movie
could get pushed to marvel face seven but kevin
feige said he didn't want to wait that long for
x-men inside the mcu i'll do more videos as we get
more easter eggs for those in the upcoming series
like anytime that kang shows up in a project we'll
probably be talking about this like loki season
two episodes and during ant-man 3. there's still
a bunch of announcements and stuff that i'm doing
videos for so i'll try to get those out as fast
as possible there's a couple big trailers too so
make sure you enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that everyone click here for my black
panther wakanda forever trailer video in easter
eggs and click here for my ant-man 3 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!